With Star Wars: The Last Jedi almost upon
us, it's time to ask the important questions:
who is Snoke?
Is Luke truly the last Jedi?
Who are Rey's parents?
And of course, who's not going to make it
out alive?
It's all but a given that somebody will bite
it in the name of plot progression, but some
characters are more likely to rejoin the Force
than others.
These Star Wars favorites stand a very good
chance of not making it to Episode 9, and
here's why.
Poe Dameron
Poe's a pretty popular and likeable character,
but he's definitely the third most important
hero in the New Trilogy, behind Rey and Finn.
So, if one of the young good guys has to go,
it's almost certainly going to be him.
If he does die, it would actually be a long
time coming.
Poe wasn't originally going to make it out
of The Force Awakens alive.
But actor Oscar Isaac asked for a bigger role
because he was sick of checking out so early
on in his films.
Ultimately, director J.J. Abrams promoted
him to "main character" status, but the fact
that they've considered axing him before suggests
they could consider it again.
Finn might want to find a backup buddy, just
in case.
General Hux
If The Last Jedi is to be the Empire Strikes
Back of the New Trilogy, that means the villains
will dominate.
But that doesn't mean they all have to survive—'cause
somebody has to take one for the dark team.
No way will that be Kylo or Snoke; they're
too important to the story's core.
So that means the First Order's General Hux
might be on the chopping block.
He's not Force-sensitive, and he and Kylo
Ren are constantly at each other's throats
over strategy.
If they clash badly enough that Snoke's forced
to choose one, he's almost certainly going
to choose Kylo over the powerless military
dude.
So what if he's really, really good at commanding
stormtroopers?
That's not a unique skill set, and Snoke could
likely find a replacement fast.
In fact, he's already got one: Captain Phasma.
Of course, she's not a guaranteed survivor
of this sequel either …
Captain Phasma
Whether or not Hux meets his end in The Last
Jedi, Phasma may be running out of time as
well and could finally face the fate she evaded
at the trash compactor in The Force Awakens.
Phasma's a pretty popular character, thanks
to the fact that she's female, portrayed by
Game of Thrones' Gwendoline Christie, and
rocks some silver, rather than the usual drab
white.
But there hasn't been a lot to her character
yet besides being a tough, stoic leader.
We haven't seen her face, and we know little
about the reasons behind what she does and
how she feels about it.
Unless The Last Jedi tackles those issues,
or at least makes her more human by showing
her face, losing her wouldn't really affect
Star Wars one way or the other.
Chewbacca
Just about any Original Trilogy character
could be knocking on the midichlorians' door,
and lovable old Chewie is no different.
Now that his partner and best buddy Han is
no more, and now that we have the Porgs to
fill the saga's "fuzzy adorable creature"
quota, Chewbacca's suddenly pretty expendable.
Besides, Chewie's actor, Peter Mayhew, is
simply too old to continue playing the role.
Lucasfilm found another seven-footer to wear
the fuzzy suit, but it's not easy to recast
a character so beloved.
It might be prudent for Disney to give us
new-guy Chewie for just one movie, so we can
say a proper goodbye to our beloved arm-ripping
teddy bear.
Then we can watch him sacrifice himself heroically
in battle, taking as many of the First Order
with him as he can, just like Han would've
wanted.
Unkar Plutt
When last we saw Unkar Plutt, he was raging
because Rey refused to sell him BB-8 and then
flew off in the Millennium Falcon, which he
claimed was his.
Aside from that, he's been a dangling plot
piece—a guy who has no real role anymore,
but who hasn't died yet either… despite
having his arm ripped off in a deleted scene.
(what watching Episode I feels like)
So unless The Last Jedi plans to make him
a major pain in the neck for Rey, it's best
to just end him.
In fact, get rid of him anyway, because he
deserves it.
Admiral Ackbar
Of all the Original Trilogy characters to
survive this long, few are more surprising
than Admiral Ackbar.
He has no real ties to the plot, and his character
is almost entirely based on his Return of
the Jedi line that the internet meme machine
has immortalized.
"It's a trap!"
Aside from that, though, he's almost completely
expendable, and one bit of dialogue isn't
enough to justify keeping him around to see
the end of Rey's saga.
Maz Kanata
The wizened Maz Kanata is a Yoda-esque figure
for the new generation, but we still don't
know much about her or her intentions.
Perhaps the mystery is meant to segue into
a spin-off or novelization; but there's also
a chance she may just be meant as a red herring
who's ready to join the other Force ghosts.
The First Order already attacked her planet
once, so why not do it again and go after
whoever remains?
It's likely they'll want to come after her
anyway, if they find out she was the one who
gave Luke's lightsaber to Rey.
And since she's not a fighter—despite being
Force-sensitive—once she's in the First
Order's sights her days are probably numbered,
cool Yoda vibes or not.
R2-D2
While a robot's life doesn't end the way fleshy
species' lives do, think of the emotional
wallop if one of the only two characters to
appear in every single Star Wars movie finally
expired.
If it were to happen, our guess is R2-D2 would
be the one to go.
"R2D2 has been in low power mode ever since
Master Luke went away."
While C-3PO is certainly beloved, there's
something about R2-D2 that makes him extra
lovable.
Maybe it's his compact size.
Maybe it's how he doesn't speak English, so
he can't talk and snark too much like his
chatty golden buddy.
Whatever it is, people adore R2-D2, and if
he gets damaged beyond repair during a dogfight,
Star Wars may actually bring audiences to
tears.
Plus, since Kenny Baker, the actor who spent
the most time inside the R2 suit, passed away
in August 2016, it only seems right that the
character go with him, so it remains his forever.
Luke Skywalker
Obi-Wan became one with The Force, so why
not the new Obi-Wan, too?
Jedi Master Luke Skywalker's getting on in
years, his friend Han Solo is gone, and his
confidence in his ability to train young Jedi
is shot.
There's no real reason to think Luke will
survive Last Jedi, aside from the fact that
he's Luke Skywalker and Star Wars would seem
weird without him.
But with new fighters like Rey and Finn now
around to pick up the slack, Luke can comfortably
join his father and Obi-Wan in the pantheon
of Force ghosts.
After all, he does give this grave warning:
"It's time for the Jedi to end."
General Leia
After Carrie Fisher's tragic and untimely
passing in December 2016, people started wondering
what would happen to her Star Wars character,
General Leia.
It's not as though anyone else can ever step
into the role, so surely, Leia will be gone
alongside her actress.
But the character was originally set to survive
The Last Jedi, to have a bigger role in Episode
9.
That's obviously no longer the case, but director
Rian Johnson has said that they aren't adjusting
what happens to her in this movie based on
real-life events.
Despite his words, though, the trailer certainly
seems to indicate her fate is questionable
in The Last Jedi all the same.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!